on nous avertit à 10h30 par téléphone
qui avait une réunion supplémentaire en
urgence pour que la direction lui fasse
une proposition la réunion a duré un
quart d'heure
elle n'était pas au programme mais s'est
rajouté une cinquième réunion
syndicats-direction autour de la table
pour continuer les négociations sur
l'augmentation du temps de travail d'une
journée marathon
la dernière pour espérer aboutir à un
accord cette réunion la direction fait
une proposition d'une prime
exceptionnelle et ponctuelle à la
signature de l'accord de 100 euros bruts
et de passer les heures supplémentaires
de 37 à 45 à 43 heures depuis 33 à +40 %
et vous avez redit que c'était on ne
sait rien c'est rien du tout donc nous
on reste celui à qui les 35 heures et on
signera pasta qu une quarantaine de
militants cgt des autres aux usines du
groupe sont venus en soutien pour dire
non à l'augmentation du temps de travail
ici sur le site de vesoul un combat
partagé par le leader de la cgt chez psa
jean pierre merci qui craint pour les
autres sites
on a lancé une pétition sur tous les
sites de psa on a récolté plus de dix
mille deux cents signatures pour d'abord
refusé les 37 heures 45
ici à vesoul et pour maintenir les 35
heures sur toutes les usines du groupe
alors il ya eu quelques avancées sur les
4 dernières réunions une augmentation du
temps de travail qui se concrétise par
une augmentation salariale de 3,1 pour
cent
la direction proposait 2,8 80 embauches
sur trois ans des investissements sur le
site de vesoul
oui mais le compte n'y est pas pour
d'autres syndicats comme force ouvrière
nous avions demandé lors d'une réunion
de négociations précédentes 200
euros on va dire net annuel aujourd'hui
on n'y est pas une journée marathon avec
de nombreux rebondissements puisque la
direction de psa ici sur le site de
vesoul avait proposé aux syndicats de se
retrouver en début d'après midi pour
signer un accord sur l'augmentation du
temps de travail l'horaire a été déplacé
après en fin d'après midi puis ce soir
on apprenait la venue du délégué central
force ouvrière sur le site pour
rencontrer le directeur pour le moment
aucun accord n'est signé et on
envisagerait peut-être une sixième
réunion demain matin